hallo da bin ich wieder an ifa aus dem
oldenburger münsterland die landwirtin
ist genervt vom schlechten image der
bauern
deshalb dreht anita lucassen videos in
ihrem kuhstall ihre mission ein
positives bild schaffen von landwirten
wie sie was mich am meisten stört ist
dass die landwirte verfall an den
pranger gestellt gestellt werden dass
durch negative beispiele
wir landwirte skandalisiert und als
umwelt muster und vier fehler
dargestellt werden die videos
veröffentlicht sie auf der
internetplattform youtube
alle sollen sehen dass es ihren tieren
gut geht das muss ohne großes
werbebudget gehen
hallo da bin ich wieder annika aus dem
oldenburger münsterland
heute möchte ich euch zeigen die da
abläuft bemerken ist dass die kurze zeit
ein wenig zappeln sind liegt daran dass
die fliegen wo man immer wieder zurück
ihr mann michael lucassen übernimmt ihre
arbeit wenn sie dreht
unser problem ist glaube ich wir sind
eine schwimmende gesellschaft die
landwirtschaft ansehen wir werden immer
weniger betriebe und die bevölkerung
entfernt die immer mehr von der
landschaft da habe ich das immer weniger
werden und in den dörfern auch immer
weniger betriebe existieren es ist immer
schwieriger den verbraucher das nahe zu
bringen
die 39 jährige ist auf einem bauernhof
mit milchkühen groß geworden
seit mehr als zehn jahren führt sie
zusammen mit ihrem ehemann ihren eigenen
betrieb sie hat 320 tiere
dafür braucht sie 105 hektar land viele
flächen sind hinzu gepachtet das kostet
im jahr mindestens 40.000 euro die tiere
stehen das ganze jahr im stall und
bekommen eine spezielle fütterung aus
mais gemischt mit kraftfutter
kritiker nennen das massentierhaltung in
einer region wo sehr hohe preise sind
und wir haben ja eine intensiv geführte
herde die 1
eine milchleistung von etwa 11.000 liter
pro jahr hat der deutsche durchschnitt
liegt bei etwa 8500 liter pro jahr um
das war in relation zu setzen und wir
können halt eben diese preise nicht
erwirtschaften wenn wir nicht diese hohe
milchleistung hätten 11.000 liter pro
jahr pro kuh tierschützer fordern mehr
weiter haltung doch nur ein kleiner teil
der herde ist draußen für die
hochleistungskühe ist das gras viel zu
mager
sie sehen sich nicht als ein teil der
agrarindustrie sondern als ein
familienunternehmen mit einem
angestellten und einem lehrling
monatelang war die milchpreise im keller
oft unter 30 cent pro liter
wie soll ein unternehmen da
wirtschaftlich seien fragen sie bei
ihrer familie bleibt wenig hängen
manchmal unter 2000 euro im monat
heute bin ich hier mit euch bei den
kälber retten und möchte euch zeigen die
kälber eigentlich aus dem mülleimer
sagen wir haben wir ein häkchen das
schon fleißig am trinken ist ihre videos
zeigen mit romantik kathi moderne
tierzucht wenig zu tun
anita lucassen befruchtet zum beispiel
ihre kühe künstlich herrn management für
jede kuh einen passenden bullen das
erbgut von 25 männlichen verärgern kauft
sie ein
diese kühe bekommen bald kälber ziel
ihrer zucht sind gesunde
hochleistungskühe die viel milch geben
und möglichst ohne hörner geboren werden
für naturschützer einbruch der ethik die
landwirte denkt da praktisch denn die
hörner in akku können gefährlich sein
man steht gerade daneben und hat dann
das spitze horn mindestens ein blauer
fleck wenn ich eine sehr heftige
prellung bis dann halt so tödlichen
verletzungen die dadurch passieren
können die videos der landwirte sind im
internet schon über eine million mal
angeklickt das zeigt die menschen
interessieren sich dafür woher ihr essen
kommt